Candis baby and he told us what projects
were involved in I'm on a show called
attack of the show on g4 daily live show
okay and Kantos how you got that job to
define your agent or yeah agent through
a series of auditions the girl that was
there before me she ended up leaving and
I had been working here and there on the
show over about a year and when you were
going through the testing phase did you
have to go back each show each show they
work on it's different this testing
process was because it's a live show
and a few different girls and we were
weak so we did the live show for a week
and then it was like um over a month
until I heard that I got it and I was
just like oh my gosh just tell me if I
have it or not so I was like maybe after
I tell actors to not overthink things
you can said that a month is a long time
you have to do your best to go in and
then after you're done just like try
your hardest to forget about it I mean
it's easier said than done but if you
think about it constantly you'll drive
yourself crazy so what would you do to
forget about would you just
keep myself busy try to read other
things hang out with friends watch
movies whatever anything to like get my
mind off of that okay was there ever a
point that she wanted to quit
oh yeah it would stop I mean yes because
the rejection you know there's a lot of
rejection stick with it you can do the
hard time so much keeping cocktail
waitressing if you like good babysitting
at all that's not a job and you're like
yeah did you have a mantra keeping that
mindset just for you
yeah just gotta keep keep going keep it
keep pushing
look thank you